are you coming to Qatar for the World
Cup if so here are five things you can
do while here number one a desert trip
[Music]
a great way to explore qatar's desert is
Dune bashing you can book a tour with a
trained driver they usually include
activities such as camel rides and more
and in this unique spot right here the
sand dunes meet the sea this Bay known
as the Inland sea forms a natural border
between Qatar and Saudi Arabia lots of
people go for a dip and even camp out
here
2. doha's museums
two that should be on your list are the
Museum of Islamic Art which showcases 14
centuries of Islamic Art and artifacts
from around the world and the national
museum of Qatar it's well known for its
unique design which was inspired by the
Desert Rose crystal here you can learn
about the history of the Arabian Gulf
all the way through to modern day Qatar
3.
if you want to experience Qatari culture
sukwakif is the place to go it's one of
the oldest markets in the country and
has been renovated to preserve its
traditional architecture
there are lots of small shops that sell
clothing spices jewelry and more and you
can grab a bite to eat at one of the
restaurants or cafes
4. purple Island
if you love nature or want to get away
from the city bustle visit purple Island
this area on the Northeast Coast is
filled with mangroves that you can kayak
through and it's home to a variety of
marine life and birds
and if you're lucky you might even spot
a flamingo and number five a boat tour
one of the classics is a tour on a
traditional wooden Dao boat you can find
boats like this lined up on the Harbor
in central Doha and you can just hop on
and go for a ride and it gives you some
pretty great views of the skyline
there will be lots of other events and
activities planned around the world cup
so there will be plenty to do and see
during a visit to Qatar